[Music]
on this monday night
a manitoba family's nightmare a young
father
hospitalized with coven i'm learning how
to walk again
and in ontario the parking lot party
defying pandemic rules
the fury over belarus forcing a flight
to land
to arrest a journalist this is an
unprecedented attack
plus dating and vaccinating proof of
vaccination opens doors to all kinds of
things
it could mean the difference between
swiping left or right
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with breaking news about
manitoba the federal government says
it's deploying the red cross
and the armed forces to help the
province get through its brutal third
wave
today manitoba reported 353
new cases more than five thousand
manitobans are now dealing
with active infections manitoba is still
by far
the hardest hit province in terms of the
infection rate per capita
in the last seven days 240 of every 100
000 people tested positive and there's
so much pressure on hospitals in that
province
that four more critically ill patients
have had to be transferred to hospitals
in ontario a total of 14 manitobans are
now receiving care in ontario
as heather york's west explains in
tonight's top story
the worst of this wave may still be
ahead
18 19. chris eastford considered himself
healthy
and strong but when he contracted kovid
19 last month
it was less than a week before the 35
year old found himself
in intensive care when they told me like
it's time for
essentially a medically induced coma
that crushed me that it devastated me
the manitoba dad spent 12 days on a
ventilator
his wife left to watch over facetime
unsure if her
husband would ever come home our son is
only 15 months old now
and she was concerned just as much as i
was
that he might not have a dad at the end
of it eastford was not eligible for the
vaccine when he became sick
he's now recovering but it's a similar
story for many others who got infected
during manitoba's severe third wave
younger patients who have now filled
manitoba's intensive care units to
capacity 11 of the province's 74 covid
icu patients
are less than 40 years old our coveted
units are full
and our patients are backing up into our
emergency departments so we have
covert patients who are intubated and
ventilated in the emergency department
others are being transferred to
hospitals across ontario for care
what we're hearing is we haven't reached
our pcap
that last week we were hearing our peak
was two to four weeks away
the third wave came later for canada's
prairie provinces
alberta is also now dealing with more
patients in intensive care
than ever before we've never seen this
many patients in issues in alberta so
you know we're really drawing from
everywhere to manage you know both
in terms of finding physical space to
fit the patients as well as
finding healthcare personnel who are
trained and able to look after the
patients
the good news for that province after
hitting a record high
last week icu patient volumes are now
beginning to fall
suggesting alberta's third wave may have
peaked
something manitoba can only hope will
happen soon
heather urex west global news calgary
there was a tough setback today for
people in newfoundland and labrador
restrictions have been expanded in that
province to try and contain a growing
outbreak
gander and several other communities in
central newfoundland are now under
alert level four that's the second
highest in the province
it means no indoor dining bars gyms and
arenas
must stay closed testing is available
for anyone in these affected communities
so please get tested
even if you do not have symptoms if you
are in this region and you do have
symptoms
it is very likely not a cold more than
30 cases have been linked to the cluster
in central newfoundland
public health officials say some of the
spread took place at social gatherings
and sporting events a large event took
place in ontario this long weekend
despite
strict covenanting restrictions hundreds
of people gathered in pickering just
east of toronto
for a parking lot party police say they
were aware of the event
but ashawn o'shea explains they didn't
do anything to stop it
at least one person was injured but the
result could have been much worse
car lovers took over this pickering
shopping mall parking lot east of
toronto
lots of people man over probably a
thousand people here
cars modified everything it was supposed
to be safe according to jonathan bola
who came to watch stay in your cars but
a lot of people didn't do that
instead some did this
drift donuts yeah they were drifting all
the way around here
driving tight circles in the packed
crowd what these people have done
is disrupted our community floundered
before the colbit regulations so it's
just unacceptable
this is the parking lot where the show
took place a day later you can see the
skid marks where those
cars kept going around and around police
let it all happen
even though their station is just two
blocks away
officers knew about the event they were
at the road outside the parking lot but
they didn't try to break it up
they weren't worried about people that
were in the lot they're worried about
people that were leaving the lot
durham police said in a tweet they'll be
following up on this matter
earlier on sunday toronto police also
stood and watched demonstrators at city
hall
protesters at a pop-up clinic noisily
trying to discourage parents from
vaccinating their children
a toronto lawyer documenting the event
says she was struck while police stood
by
as far as enforcement we've seen a lot
of latitude given to
protests so beyond that
i would say definitely they shouldn't be
hitting people
the police are doing their best to
ensure public safety on that that
broader scale
but in cases like these staying back
even when what's going on
isn't allowed me and my friends we're
surprised that this thing didn't get
shut down
a parking lot party out of control shawn
o'shea global news pickering ontario
ontario has hit another promising point
in its vaccination campaign
according to the province a total of
eight million doses have now been given
out
one million of those went into arms in
the last week overall more than 51
percent of canadians have now had at
least
one dose 4.3 percent have been fully
vaccinated
compared to the last few weeks this week
will be much slower for vaccine
deliveries
only 600 000 pfizer biotech doses are
expected but starting in june
pfizer deliveries should reach 2.4
million doses
per week in japan efforts are underway
to vaccinate the country's elderly
population ahead of the olympics
mass vaccination centers are now
operating in tokyo and
other major cities the goal is to
vaccinate thousands of people over the
age of 65
every day the government hopes the
centers will boost japan's sluggish
vaccine drive
large parts of the country are under a
state of emergency as japan struggles to
battle a fourth wave of copin 19.
today the u.s urged its citizens against
traveling to japan
because of a sharp rise in cases the
head of the united nations is calling on
world leaders to do more to help poor
countries fight coven 19.
the u.n secretary general says the world
is at war with the virus and the battle
is far from over
sadly unless we act now we face a
situation which rich countries vaccinate
the majority of their people
and open their economies while the virus
continues to cause deep suffering
by circling and mutating in the poorest
countries
for the spikes and surges could claim
hundreds of thousands of lives and slow
the global economic recovery
antonio gutierrez says the pandemic has
already brought a tsunami of suffering
with more than 3.4 million deaths
the bulk of them in the u.s brazil and
india
world leaders are condemning the actions
of belarus tonight
the european union is taking it a step
further vowing to place new sanctions on
the country including a ban
on the use of the bloc's airspace and
airports
yesterday a fighter jet forced a
commercial airliner to divert to belarus
capital
citing a bomb threat but as soon as the
plane landed
a journalist critical of the president
was arrested
as redmond shannon explains the
situation will require the eu to strike
a delicate balance
to prevent russia from getting involved
this is the first video of belarusian
journalist roman pradesevich
since his arrest at minsk airport sunday
he says he's in good health and that he
was involved in organizing
anti-government protests
following last year's disputed elections
the country's
also exiled opposition leader fears for
his fate
lawyer is already trying to
get him but we don't know the updated
information at the moment
but i'm sure that he's in awful
circumstances
svetlana tikanovsky tweeted that he
appears to be
under physical and moral pressure the
country's main
independent news outlet was shut down by
the government this month
and more journalists were jailed but
sunday's events appear to have taken the
crackdown to a new level
on monday the lukashenko regime blamed
hamas
for issuing a fake bomb threat against
the passenger jet
carrying pradesevich the plane was
ordered to land in belarus
sunday during a flight from greece to
lithuania
hamas has denied the claim it is
unjustifiable that ordinary
international travelers have been held
hostage to the regime's aggression
world leaders have called it a hijacking
the european union has banned its
flights from crossing over belarus
and says it will impose new sanctions
against the lukashenko regime
if we don't have a strong response it's
going to be you know endless
events like this and we can't afford
this
belarus literally sits between the eu
and russia
it's a difficult balance for the west to
strike according to this
former belarusian diplomat if you put
russia and belarus to the same box
and put in this putting them on the same
sanctions package this will bring
lukashanka
uh close to putin and he it would be
easier for him to ask
for some economic support lukashenka is
reportedly set to meet with russian
leader vladimir putin
later this week redmond shannon global
news london
access denied coming up why samoa's
first female prime minister
was locked at a parliament plus the nose
knows
more proof pooches are valuable weapons
in the fight against kovin
italy's government has launched an
investigation into a cable car crash
that killed 14 people
the lone survivor a five-year-old
israeli boy living in italy
is in intensive care his parents brother
and two
great-grandparents died investigators
say the lead cable snapped and the
emergency brake failed
the car began to reverse and hit a pylon
before plunging
19 meters to the ground
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
is on route to the middle east to help
secure
a more lasting peace deal the ceasefire
between israel and hamas
is holding but a stabbing today in the
east jerusalem neighborhood that became
a flash point in this recent conflict
shows how volatile the situation remains
jennifer johnson reports and a warning
some of the images are disturbing u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken has
left for israel
pledging humanitarian aid for the people
of gaza before meeting in jerusalem to
try and broker a peace deal
ultimately it is the only way to ensure
israel's future
as a jewish and democratic state and of
course the only way to give the
palestinians the state to which
they're entitled as the cease-fire
stretches into its fourth day
tensions are simmering police say a
knife-wielding palestinian was shot in
east jerusalem
after two people one an israeli soldier
were stabbed
hamas military has paraded through the
streets of gaza
declaring victory in the deadly conflict
but israelis are claiming victory too
i'm against the ceasefire with gaza i
think we should continue the fighting
we're fighting for
our freedom that's the only way
in cities across america there are more
pro-palestine rallies
protesters are condemning the israeli
strikes that killed at least 100 women
and children in gaza
demonstrators want the u.s to stop
selling israel military equipment
there is a pending bill in the senate to
delay those sales
the united states of america has got to
be leading the world
in bringing people together not simply
supplying weapons
to kill children in gaza israel says
hamas uses women and children as human
shields
storing weapons in places they know
israel will hit the strikes have turned
some public opinion against israel
in the u.s anti-jewish incidents are
dramatically increasing
including the smashing of this
synagogue's door right now it's just a
rock
and they just broke our window but i
don't want to know what's next
five u.s jewish groups have written to
president biden
asking him to take action against the
rise in anti-jewish hate crimes
jennifer johnson global news washington
before leaving for the middle east
blinken slapped new sanctions on
ethiopia
the country's forces are accused of
human rights violations and atrocities
in the tigray region
where a conflict has raged for more than
six months blinken says the u.s is
taking steps to impose visa restrictions
on those believed to be responsible for
perpetuating the conflict
ethiopia is accusing the u.s of meddling
in internal affairs
the woman elected as samoa's first
female prime minister was sworn in today
in a ceremony that was anything but
traditional
fiammi naomi matafa took the oath of
office
in a tent outside the house of
government because the man she's about
to replace
locked her out her party claimed a
narrow majority in last month's election
besting incumbent tulepa saleli
malalagawi
matafa was once his deputy pm until she
broke away to challenge him there have
been weeks of turmoil in the south
pacific nation
the supreme court had to intervene and
ordered parliament to convene
so the new government could take power
still ahead their sense of smell is
helping sniff out covid19
some optimism to share tonight in terms
of how fast and how accurately covet 19
can be detected
researchers in the united kingdom
working with specially trained dogs
found the animals quickly identified the
virus 94
of the time now this is important
because there are parts of the world
still battling rising infections and as
crystal gamansing reports
these canines may be our new friends in
this pandemic fight
that's a good boy those puppy dog eyes
may make you melt but their noses could
actually save your life the dogs could
detect correctly if somebody was
infected with covet
94 of the time and what's really
incredible about these dogs
is that they can do it really really
quickly the findings come from a joint
research project between london school
of hygiene
and tropical medicine and durham
university
for months they have worked with six
medical detection dogs
teaching them to recognize the scent of
covet 19
and testing the dog's ability to
identify samples
and interestingly they could do it
irrespective of the level of virus that
the patients had
so they could detect people with low
viral loads
just as readily as they could those
people with high
viral loads the findings have not been
peer reviewed but they
are in line with other canine trials a
pilot project at the helsinki airport
last year
saw dogs correctly identify nearly every
sample
thai researchers reported their dogs had
a 95 percent success rate
with roughly 2 000 samples dogs are now
being deployed in bangkok
the extra help comes as the virus takes
a heavy toll more cases have been
reported so far this year
than in the whole of 2020.
on current trends the number of deaths
will overtake
last year's total within the next three
weeks
quickly identifying cases and isolating
those who are ill
is key to keeping the virus from
spreading this is something that could
really change
the way in which diagnostics look
because you could
do a rapid screen and then follow it up
with a pcr test
researchers say it's still early but
several countries are working with dogs
to confirm how our four-legged friends
can help in the fight against coveted
19.
crystal gomencing global news london
up next the new feature in dating apps
that may
improve your shot at love
a couple in india skirted that country's
coveted 19 restrictions and
tied the knot on a chartered flight
crammed with family and friends
there were 160 people on board the
two-hour flight
india's aviation authority has now
launched an investigation
the airline spicejet says the plane was
booked by a travel agent
airport staff say they were unaware of
the couple was planning the sky high
ceremony
are you looking for love dating isn't
easy in a pandemic
first there's the risk of getting the
virus in an intimate moment
then there's the vaccination situation
now some apps have an added feature to
give single people
another shot at finding a perfect match
here's catherine ward
the pandemic has dealt a tough hand for
those looking for love
you don't really get a feel of exactly
how the person is when you're just
chatting with them online
while i have been out of the dating game
for some time
my friends tell me the stakes feel so
much higher with covet 19.
i found that i was always the person
having to create the boundaries around
physical distancing
and to state my boundaries and those
things and some guys were into it and
some guys weren't
pre-pandemic people might have been
searching for a partner of a certain age
gender religion or background but in
2021
many want to know your vaccine status
people do want to know and people are
asking up front
even if being vaccinated isn't like 100
your thing
or important to you your health should
be in the u.s on friday the government
teamed up with several dating websites
trying to encourage people to get a shot
social distancing and dating
were always a bit of a challenging
combination on okcupid for example
users in the us can now display badges
indicating they've been vaccinated and
also filter out people who haven't
if a person participates the company
also provides incentives they plan to
expand this globally
it's not clear if other companies will
follow suit
in a statement from bumble a
spokesperson says vaccine badges and
complementary super swipes are currently
u.s only it's a kind of vaccine passport
in some ways
still some experts are not discounting
the idea proof of vaccination opens
doors to all kinds of things
like maybe theaters travel schools
certain jobs
why not dating because while a vaccine
may or may not
be a deal breaker i did meet someone
online i knew that he
was eligible for a vaccine and he just
hadn't signed up yet it very well
could be part of your love story it's
kind of a condition of dating me
that you make an appointment to get
vaccinated and he said okay i will
catherine ward global news toronto it's
a whole new level
to modern love and that is global
national for this monday night i'm robin
gill
tonight your canada is the prairie lily
riverboat in saskatoon
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
we'll be back tomorrow and i'll see you
next weekend
have a great night
you